[Music]
this isn't a movie Game of Thrones sets
up earlier that it's gonna be 67% of
horse-riding also you didn't have one
other sucker on the watch that could
have joined you on this expedition so
that when you split off it didn't have
to be solo something strange in your
neighborhood who you gonna call no one
absolutely no one you've got two buddies
right around the corner but sure backup
is overrated I always wondered what ever
happened to the Knights who say me also
later he got reprimanded by the white
Walker Council for his sloppy
decapitated head on stake placement
stupid Larry surprised but how did you
not see her on your way in
apparently sir feather stash has no
peripheral vision eight heads eight
torsos 13 legs 14 arms and seven limbs
that could go either way if my serial
killer math is correct where did those
two extra limbs come from they're
savages one not steals a goat from
another lot before you know they're
ripping each other to pieces that's
Wilding us to the dead frighten you know
but ritualistic dismemberment and corpse
landscaping might do the trick they even
killed the children it's a good thing
we're not children discount Matt Damon
will be your know-it-all in charge that
is certain to get his comeuppance role
for this episode enjoy it that men seem
to have moved camp they were here wait
is this supposed to be where young Clint
Howard look-alike found the dead bodies
because there is no way all this was
moved by the time it took them to get
over here white walkers well created by
magic have never been known to actually
have the magical abilities it would take
to teleport decapitated heads and body
obviously shows do opening credits but
did we really need almost two minutes of
this living map Gilligan's Island and
Brady Bunch expositor their entire
backstory in 60 seconds let's get to
some throne gaming already go on
father's watching no no winter is coming
wrong line bastard too young to say such
things I'm sure he's seen much worse on
the winter net already those Ravens will
bring you anything if you're willing to
wait a few weeks winter is coming
roll commercials I should have compacted
a warm one on bottom so I saw then not
deserting and letting everyone know
would probably have been a great idea
and we get to keep your head so win-win
also isn't the wall like 600 miles from
Winterfell how do people cover those
kinds of distances on foot so quickly
did Elon Musk install a Westeros
Hyperloop but do you understand why I
had to kill him I'm gonna go with HBO
demanded a death scene every 10 minutes
and
passes the sentence should swing the
sword I like this Eddard Stark fella
steadfast and full of integrity I'm
really excited to have someone to root
for through the entire run of this
series good thing he's not going
anywhere madman sees what he sees this
in no way answers the question also my
family has a similar expression it goes
something like a madman lets his son
watch him decapitate an innocent man
with a broadsword the sheer scope of
this show is both a huge strength and a
huge weakness sure each new location and
character deepens the world but on the
other hand there's no way I'm
remembering all these places and names
which is why I end up referring to
people as that one dragon lady or the
incest twins only seven you jumped off
the cliffs at Casterly Rock 100-foot
drop into the water you were never
afraid to characters we know zero about
but sure let's dive headfirst into a
story from their past upon meeting them
this is also known as Martin's position
and life will go along on this show
maybe not is it just me or does Ned seem
a little too into this sword cleaning
someone may love their sword just a
little too much more news
I put the comic section on your bed for
later brand up the sports section but
I'm pretty sure the Ravens scammed us
because I can't find the arts on
lifestyle page spider brand spider
breath does whatever a spider brain does
how many times have I told you no
climbing climb shadowing for climbing
now this hound helmet looks super cool
it seems insanely impractical PLAs oh
yeah son so where's your sister as rare
as a king's visit to Winterfell is
wouldn't Lady Stark have noticed before
now that one of her children was missing
Arya clearly keeps up with her King's
Landing beep I have a son you have a
daughter Senate will join our houses
I wish arranged marriages were that easy
the last time I tried to arrange a
marriage with my son of my friend stoner
this fast I got a restraining order from
Billy Ray Cyrus it is true what they say
about the northern girls when they were
riding into Winterfell and the Royal
Order did tyrion just cut out and make a
beeline for the [ __ ] barn without
anyone noticing may I present my honored
guests this series of House Targaryen
I feel like why is illyrio speaking
dothraki now when he just introduced an
heiress and Viserys to them in English
do you take me for a fool I take you for
a cane you'd think with the constant
treachery that is the hallmark of
Westeros the people who live here would
evolve to know when smoke is being blown
up their ass I would let his whole tribe
q:o 40,000 men and their horses - that's
what it took brothers what are you gonna
do am i right do you think Joffrey will
like me what if he thinks I'm okay I
know this is the dark ages and such but
if Sansa had an Instagram I get the
feeling the amount of selfies on it
would likely outnumber the amount of
candles in the entirety of Westeros you
are the busted though no did it
Stuckey's my father and Lady Stark is
not your mother making you bastard
biology brought to you by Game of
Thrones also if you were playing the
bastard drinking game this scene alone
would give you alcohol poisoning she
doing at the Eyrie she hasn't been back
there since her wedding I get that you
want to destroy but why not at least
show Ned and then destroy a second pair
of eyes couldn't hurt no she says Jon
Arryn was murdered by the Lannisters not
even gonna give LuAnn a chance to get
out so he's not privy to info that could
lead to his death that's harsh as this
news is true and the Lannisters conspire
against the throne who but you can
protect the king Godfather of Thrones
meanwhile at Burning Man episode really
shoehorns in the nuptials of Daenerys
and call with as interesting as the
Winterfell drama is this couldn't have
waited until episode 2 I piss on
Dothraki omens I've waited 17 years to
get my phone back
I didn't realize Viserys was Targaryen
for one-dimensional [ __ ] anyway we
can speed up his demise anyone at the
wedding have a pot of molten gold handy
anyone Gor play a Dothraki wedding
without at least three deaths is
considered a dull affair much like how
HBO execs picked their shows we need at
least three deaths at a wedding or five
boobs at a funeral your call here they
shoot Daenerys so that the heat shimmer
from the fire is behind her and later
with the fire the sunset wait
is this show actually smart - dragons
eggs Daenerys whoever has to follow this
gift better have something good I would
need to be the guy going next that got
them a toaster twincest the things I do
for love
well technically power and deception but
sure tell yourself whatever you need to
[Music]
is what brings us together today look
away don't even blink blink and you're
dead
Robert will choose a new hand of the
king someone to do his job well himself
in boars and hunting [ __ ] tell me
about your Naren I mean what if next
Friday 400 women turn around and say
he's too fat he's too old Ernie is a
pigeon chested little tosser where's
Lenny okay the things I do for love
[Music]